look got a three Texas girls hanging out
I like this I really do we're taking
over New York we're taking and we just
ran into each other I don't know if you
remember I was at um Chelsea Handler's
um stand up yes it was backstage I know
I was like totally not hair makeup I
don't look like this outside and I was
like I don't know if she knows who I am
but I was like hi what's up but anyway I
saw you you you had a whole crew there
as well it was so fun it was really fun
how hilarious is Chelsea Handler oh my
God everyone Sam J that open like there
were it was like such a fun night and it
just reminded me like it's one of the
reasons why I moved here I want a life
um but I how so important I do the
comedy is so important and it's it makes
you feel so good yes it was hilarious
and so fun and she's the best big sister
that's not blood related to I know y'all
do I know I knew that about that but
Halloween just happened so um what did
y'all do did you go trick-or-treating
this is my first Halloween here did you
have fun it yeah it's a lot it's a lot a
lot it was different I think my kids are
too polite for this city right now they
need to yeah they got a well my son good
though if it shows you how much he loves
New York City was a New York City rat
firefighter that's very specific was a
New York City rat
firefighter and he kept um and then I
was fire oh my God I love that and a
pizza I love that I was a fire pizza one
of my daughters was an angel or my I
only have one daughter my my daughter
was an angel one of kids is what I meant
it was an angel I know they are angels
right it was very fun I think my
daughter though got a little overwhelmed
there was thousands of people it's
overwhelming I've never done it here and
I was like interesting yeah and I just I
had to kind of fight for my kids to get
up there to get candy it was insane it's
a lot what what two years old right she
two she was a kitty a meow was her first
word a so she dressed as herself
basically okay was a star cat what does
that mean just a cat with a lot of
glitter oh okay you're a fancy cat I
like it oh there we are and a blow up
that too cuz why not yeah well and by
the way we were in that inflatable which
is like a hamster ball I've done that
before and we can't move we got stuck
we're large I can't do it cuz I get sick
I get motion sickness it was hot it's
harder than you think it is and then two
little boys zoomed into us and they were
like y'all are
slow I know um so is two that's a fun
age sometimes terrible twos yet or not
yet she's Ador well you might not I
didn't get terrible twos I got three
Ager well I that's what I'm scared is
that it's just delayed and I keep saying
she's perfect and then she's going to
sneak up on me she's super joyful meow
was her first word but her other word is
no she's a totally unreliable narrator
she just know so I'll say like she'll be
eating watermelon and I'll say oh is
that watermelon no she's already
gaslighting her she's already
gaslighting her kid are the biggest G
she does it with the cutest voice
applaud it so now 15 years from now
she's been encouraged to act like this
by her mother oh my gosh I I love I miss
I don't miss as I love every age but
mine are seven and nine at this point
and it's like you just I was out
trick-or-treating with them and seen all
these little kids these little costumes
a it's very cozy very dangerous um cuz I
do not need more children um already a
single mom but um so your boy um you
have one boy and two girls right yes
okay so I have a boy and a girl that's
very different are you experiencing that
my gosh when Hal entered the equation it
was like a we didn't even know what to
do it was like all this boy energy that
our house kind of needed yeah you know
cuz it was a lot of girl things Vibes
but boys are like Tasmanian devils oh
yeah yeah no he leads with his head yeah
I mean he was also a New York City rat
for Halloween which is kind of Awesome
which is awesome the foreshadowing of
that of who he's going to be is pretty
magical it's like all right I love that
he's not afraid to be himself for sure
yeah mine loves scary and I think that's
insane cuz he's seven but he was like
Mom take a picture everything just
horribly scary he was like take a
picture take video I was like why look
back over later yeah yeah but he loves
it um so wait I want to show this photo
because this is adorable do you remember
this photo look at you I remember those
dresses with the the lace on the I have
Lally a church picture I took with my
mom and I'm wearing like something
almost identical those drop
waist not for good for girls with curves
later chubby you were not well we were
uh what not there not there but I I was
I'm like I don't think you know a chubby
I was I chubby no Barbara you can't ask
someone that she's not going to be like
you are a chub club like she Barbara was
I look at her there you're not chubby
there no not there but in my life was I
chubby well there was a stage but it was
I had a thank you I've had many stages
actually it was College it wasn't this
yeah were you always dressed alike like
did they my mom liked that often yeah we
rebelled yeah and it was fun to Rebel
you know and then we took each other's
clothes instead yeah although now I
can't fit into her
clothes h i don't fit into mine I love
losing weight are you joking me I love
losing weight but here's the
thing but jeans are so hard I I feel
like jeans are so hard when you have a
but you want me to take you Jean
shopping I don't want to go shopping
shall I just do what I do for Hoda and
send you some jeans oh my god do you do
for Hoda I'm the worst it's it's jeans
are so hard anyway we'll figure it out
this is a first world problem and it's a
great problem but I showed up today and
I was like look I didn't have anything
else to wear and they're like why are
you wearing those I like that's cute no
no my jeans I wore here they they're
bigger yeah but I was going for that
really cool TLC vibe
chasing exactly I love we're all the
same age new book is called love comes
first it's out now so you've had a
couple books right together so why this
book why love comes first okay well we
wrote about sisters sister being sisters
was sort of always our inspiration cuz
we were born with a partner there's
nothing better than having a twin yeah
so all of our first books were about
sisters and then our family started
looking different than what we had grown
up with she had a boy yeah and she had a
baby and I had a nugget nugget and so
then we wanted to write another book
that wasn't solely centered on sisters
um but more about how love there's
plenty of room for love you can have
your blood relatives you can have your
chosen family and there love is infinite
and there's always room for more and
that's what we wanted to encourage with
our we feel like there's there's room
for love in this world and if you look
at the there's a need and if you see the
way our kids act
they're just full of it you know they
know that love is infinite and adults
Jade them the thing we run it 100% so
this is for all of them that are sort of
showing us the way I love that because
Blended is so important too and also
like I didn't grow up around my brother
and sister but like I had friends that
became family I think that counts family
and that matters too yeah um so do you
you're doing a book tour right we're
going to Texas girl you are you oh yeah
oh yeah we are today we're going to get
jealous whatever remember when I brought
you that big vat remember that vat of
queso my favorite guests I know I know
for like families I know so wait are
y'all good at traveling together me and
my sister are awesome at traveling
together we're great traving together we
actually get there and they're like okay
Mrs Hagar here's your room Mrs Bush
here's yours and we're like oh no no
we'll forgo the two rooms for the
fantasy suite you know like yeah no my
sister and I are similar too when we go
on vacation I we there's always so much
of us so many of us too that we end up
like packing like going together my
sister and I are Trish and I end up
going together all the time but yeah we
always share room sh room because um
you're not really in the room a ton
you're working or you're visiting
whatever City you're in it's fun to be
with each other it gives us a slumber
party it's the road trip that we've been
desperate for exactly I love a road trip
we do too yeah um okay so what are some
of your favorite cities your favorite
moments that you've been to well we like
going to Texas we'll go to Texas this
weekend and be with our mom for her
birthday that's exciting um and we're
really excited that there was a Texas
Rangers win so we'll celebrate I I
didn't celebrate I've been like my
household has been weird with fighting
sickness so I didn't celebrate I wasn't
watching I was just being single taking
care of kid it feels like people didn't
watch but we watch we did yeah I didn't
get to watch I was so bumed but I had um
we have this whole group um text group
of sports ball people and um well it's
our fantasy league I'm into fantasy
football now yes I heard you were
hardcore what's your team just lost my
quarterback oh the red flag collectors
you know
they throw yellow F flag and I collect
red ones um anyway um we I had to get a
new quarterback whatever I'm super proud
of the Rangers was that awesome this is
very cool yeah that's how I found out
was via text but I have to say uh
Schwarzenegger was just here Arnold and
he sent the craziest story that I did
not know he broke your grandma's ankle
yeah yeah in the 9s and she wasn't super
young so that was her yeah he went
sledding with our grandfather and no
grandmother no he ran ran
[Music]
into by the way that holes like they
went sledding like can you imagine like
two 75 year olds being like Hey Arnold
let's sled kind of love it I kind of
love your family just for that that's
kind of amazing just like I can't get my
head really wrapped around he said she
took it like a chant though SP nothing
less she would definitely did yeah
strong woman I think she liked having
stories to tell too not many people can
say that that's pretty crazy I'd
probably made something out too he got
very angry at
dinner KT so you share a name with that
girl like so that was that ever hard
growing up it was awkward yeah um cuz
she was the she was the first lady
presid wife I do when she was in second
grade so like I would call dominoes and
Order think I was really responsible and
order pizza and they would hang up on me
think that I was prank calling cuz that
was really the prank calling I was like
did
prank to prank call we loved prank I
want a prank call
[Music]
[Applause]
soon thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home